[Music]
thank you for being here I'm really
excited about this panel we're very
proud that we got the largest panel at
the conference and we also have a broad
representation from people in China
Russia Italy and the UK so the goal of
this panel is to figure out what are
some opportunities and ways in which we
can strive for it more globally
coordinated well was a GI but of course
there are things that we may need you
now and potentially you could find
narratives and areas of concerns that
can bridge North German long-term
dialogue of AIT government and the way
that I think about kind of the common
tea nomination of Industry and academia
is that they are very much comprised of
scientists and researchers and as Max
said to me during lunch yesterday
the laws of physics in different parts
of the world are the same so it really
helped people to you know at the same
kind of dialogue and Jason earlier was
also talking about how Soviet Union and
us at cooperation despite the hostile
situation so that took the form of high
tech technical collaboration that took
the form of Czech 1.5 dialogue and I
think scientists play a crucial role in
facilitating those conversations so what
I want to do in this panel is that each
of us here is going to give a opening
statements for two to three minutes and
we will also have three questions around
this topic and then we can take
questions from the audience
and since Andrey is the only Russian
participant at the conference as Max
suggested it might be
also good if we can experiment from
Andre about the most unique features and
characteristics of Russian academia
industry and we can do it either in the
opening statement or later cool so
let's have Jason okay a skirt to be here
my name is Jason I come from listen we a
is important rich beautiful incident in
the past few years our Institute has fed
her who introduced advance the source of
research from the US and EU into China I
would like to talk a little about the
progress we have made recently in the
neck - the first one we are about three
years ago when we recognized that there
was a gap in understanding of the issue
of China our research and that of Bruce
Lee's Institute and a way was in
dedicated much of time to introduce a
azekah principles that developed the
overseas into China our team is the
first one to be translated as people is
a ask a catalan and also a Salama
principles in which China audience so we
also were happy to see that nowadays as
if our cinema principles are very
well-known in China we came early
everywhere in China a conference is and
also we have made some publications
about AI it covered a lot of topics that
including the technology development
industry development and also the
national strategies in privacy at all so
we're happy to know every team from
Oxford is now working on translating the
book in English and we also are bringing
here the one book is about the story was
going out about the Japan and mobile
Internet his name is at your fingertips
and another is the book is is brother
with the Cosby oh honey
and another this these three books is
available on the table you know poster I
think it was here
I spent years working for Yandex with
leading Russian IT company and after
three years working there I was heading
a group that started collaboration with
CERN with particle physicists so the
topic was bring expertise of machine
learning machine intelligence towards
fundamental science and see what kind of
change from kind of progress didn't
bring so the collaboration was very
fruitful and it was fear that to
continue and enhance this venue that the
additional resources involved and my
group has moved to a public university
now we're laboratory methods for big
data analysis there that we funded both
by government funded both by University
and by young legs or we were getting
resources from all those resources and
we can in your doing what we started
doing several years ago we collaborate
with different branches of science and
what kind of problems can be resolved by
means of in following their topic right
right right
what kind of teacher might be relevant
to Russia if briefly outlined this so
Russia has very broad history of
collaborating in various Sciences maybe
maybe not
as of HP layer not not as officially on
the government level but laboratory so
it was creation of turn Russia was
active member there
although
communication with other medications
other members of Thor was not
established on the government and it is
the case is continuing with the case of
Russia is not yet a school member or any
kind of official member
although tribution from Russian side to
the Stein's
continues to be on quite significant
level so it is funded on national level
and resources that government spent on
these are going in one way or another
don't worry developing of common common
experiment so I think that maybe maybe I
will talk about this later
so similar similar similar yeah when we
have some kind of centralized support
three along the way to exchange okay so
this is the topic of this panel is the
cooperation between a theme here in the
industry I thought that I will I will
just give some examples of these
collaborations not just on researcher
but also on best practices policies and
governance that that I'm involved with
with the idea that maybe you know we can
elaborate from these examples so the
first one is this academia and Industry
collaboration that IBM has put together
with mi
that his own AI it has four pillars some
of them are about Karen I mean Nancy the
capabilities of currently yeah but is
one of of them which is called advancing
shared prosperity with the eye which is
more related to ethics in AI a impact of
AI on jobs and his moral kind of
long-term looking so this is a model of
a very tight cooperation where there are
teams of people half in academia and
half within the company that work
together really in everyday you know
passion and so it's not easily scalable
it requires a lot of resources but it's
one model that it seems to work and
produce really interesting results aware
of academia and industry and you know
leverage the second example is what I
see happening within the partnership on
AI so that is an example of a
cooperation that two years ago I was
part of the group of five researchers
that put together this initiative and
the whole idea of the partnership or AI
was that in order to define the best
practices for advancing AI it wouldn't
will make sense to do it within each
single company or each thing called AI
producers but it would would have been
much better to do it in a cooperative
environment and not just among companies
not just among companies and academia
but where all the stakeholders were
present so that's the what happens
within the partnership where as Peter
mentioned before there are various
topics but then there are working groups
where people from all the partners and
as Peter said now we are more than 80
partners that they get together
depending on their interest on the
various working groups and they work
together to define best practice
is all that popping like fairness or
other thing but that's another model and
I think that that's a very global one
it has partners from all over the world
and of all different kind of
stakeholders those that produced the I
know that are impacted by AI and accept
government so policymakers the first
example is that that includes government
and this is a partnership that IBM has
with the World Economic Forum a World
Economic Forum has kind of policy
projects where they work together with
several companies and also possibly
academic entities to define that is a
policy for something like for example
policy for the use of drones to deliver
goods that's one example that they did
but they don't want to do it just with
companies and academia they also want to
do it with at least one government who
agrees to Pilar to be the pilot for that
policy that is going to be defined and
then possibly with that that policy can
scale up to many other governments so
that's another model that I think is
very successful because he puts together
industry academia but also governments
that actually will adopt the policy that
comes out of there another example is
what happens within a Tripoli I Tripoli
has put together this initiative or
ethical considerations for AI systems
that includes also a chapter an area
that is about AGI and and they're really
again many different stakeholders
including academia and including
corporations work together to define
recommendations for developers to handle
the various issues that can come up in
their everyday job when they have to the
design and develop a is distance so that
also a very successful model because he
put together an incredibly big
list of issues and recommendations as
well as as John said 13 or 14 working
groups for standards related to days now
and then the last one that I want to
mention is was mentioned before this the
European Commission on high-level expert
group on AI that Ian and myself are part
of this is a group of 52 people where
the ai ai experts are very small
minority
everybody else is people from other
corporations academia but also again all
the other stakeholders because the
European Commission understood that
that's the only way to get really the
right guidelines to facilitate and
support AI in Europe and and that
already delivered as I said the European
the guidelines for transport C III in
Europe and they will deliver also in the
in the future monster very soon another
document - for policies for AI in Europe
so a structure possibly research
Panthers and also mechanisms for
academia induced industry cooperation so
that's a place where the cooperation was
at the meta level how do we define
mechanisms for cooperation
so my point will be quite complementary
to the previous ones and also to
previous panels and I'd be happy to
discuss it further later on why I might
be seeming to disagree with some of the
points that have been made
my background is international law and
in that I'm mostly interested in sort of
hard line in the sticks in innocence
because I think a lot of the problems we
are facing already we have been facing
for some time with with AI and with
other software need at some point a
binding solutions and needs
kind of enforcement even if it's
hopefully not the use of force and my
point will be in this 2-3 minute
contribution that we as a community who
care about beneficial AGI should also be
contributing to ongoing global ai
governance efforts even though it's sort
of narrow yeah why because I think that
as others have mentioned these examples
provide an interesting test beds and can
provide lessons for tackling larger
challenges later and as you know we
humans tend to iterate and tend to you
know do reinforcement learning ourselves
in some way and so it's really something
that we shouldn't we shouldn't wait
until we have high stakes you know
existential risks before we start
putting even you know not just carrots
but also sticks in place and try to
monitor and try to verify with regard to
current problems so what do I mean by
international AI governance you may not
be aware of much of what's happening
because much of it doesn't really get a
lot of media attention what has gotten
most attention is as you I'm sure you
all know is the leaflet on US weapons
debate which hasn't really advanced that
much so far and he's a particularly hard
problem to make progress on given
military interests so what I mean for
instance to give some examples is the
International Civil Aviation
Organization is developing regulation
for autonomous drones and of course has
had to deal with automation in in
commercial airliners for some time as
you know it's highly automated and
they've had to deal with a lot of issues
are ready and so can provide lessons for
other other domains and it just may be
also as a sort of note on that in terms
of what's the role of of academia and
industry nowadays almost all these
processes have
participation sort of built-in multi
stakeholder participation they have you
know called for proposal for
consultation for expert advisory
committees etc and I think from from
what I I don't know how many of you
participate in these or international
level processes I know that a lot of you
participate in national like US
government or UK government or or
Chinese government these sort of
processes and this might sort of be more
what you're aware of but I would
encourage you to also look at at
international processes especially given
that you know these problems are global
or at least at some point they will be
right now it's not as widespread yet but
these problems of you know criminal use
of of ml in in either the physical world
with with drones or other things and in
virtual world of course is already the
largest thing global as we've seen with
some of the attacks like wanna cry or
these others in in recent years
so apart from civil aviation and drones
there's also illegal progress that's
been made on autonomous driving with an
amendment of the Vienna Convention on
road traffic and which is right now
looking at regulation for how to deal
with over-the-air updates with human
machine interface with cyber security of
cars with all these sort of things and
at the international level at the level
of global regulations which I think is
more sort of scalable solution than just
looking at a national thing as you in
particular we grow traffic as you guys
we've seen sometimes simple coordination
problems like should we drive on the
left or right once you've sort of
settled on a solution it's really hard
to change their path dependencies and I
think with ml as safety and security a
lot of these things are also path
dependent and we need to sort of be
participating even now while we don't
have a VI yet so others just briefly to
mention the International Maritime
Organization is working on a sort of
scoping exercise on autonomous shipping
which includes looking at legal barriers
and gaps in regulation to make it safe
and secure including things like
preventing weapons of mass destruction
proliferation through it
shaped and in the other cases of times
drones or planes also in this space
counterterrorism an arms control has
made quite a bit of progress since 9/11
there's really been sort of a but a lot
of awareness at the government level and
investment into improving international
processes and verify national compliance
with international standards and rules
industrial and service robot safety is
another domain where there's been since
the nineties there's been safety
standards and of course nowadays they're
looking at a DML another AI mechanism
not just in the past it was mostly sort
of symbolic AI but nowadays of course
they're also worried about AI ml in
addition to these domain-specific
[Music]
regimes there's also cross-domain
internationally a governance I'm
actually also going quite a way back
just like AI has quite a long history
governance of AI actually at the
international level has also quite some
history because governments I guess to
some extent were worried already back
then that they were sort of foreseeing
potential dangers that didn't that
didn't get realised that quickly but
that now are really on the top of a lot
of people's minds for instance AI based
data processing there's a 1981
Convention for the protection of
individuals with regard to automatic
processing of personal data and it this
is actually the treaty that the gdpr
implements but the treaty is much larger
than the GDP r it has 53 parties and
it's growing including in with African
states and Latin American states it
includes automatic processing by
symbolic and boat and AI and ml it
defines personal data not as just
relating to an identify it individual
but also identifiable through a
combination of different data sources
which as we know is nowadays quite easy
with the massive amounts of data that we
have on individuals and both in this
sense both inputs and outputs of ML
systems can be seen as personal data
because they relate to an individual for
instance a behavior prediction or
classification
of something even within animal system
is also in this sense personally it
relates to the same individual it was
amended in in May last year to include
additional obligations and such as an
obligation for data controllers to
conduct a prior impact assessment of
their their systems and I could go on
and on like if there's really a lot
great
so francesca and mattina have already
alluded to the point that i want to ask
the other three of you perhaps that was
academic and industry it seems that
there is a huge role to play in global
policy making that is you know if we
have all these narratives of arms raised
and other militaristic even concerns
from national governments it seems that
the cosmopolitan scientific community
can really play a role in competitive
combating the narrative or grounding the
discussions on scientific consensus so I
wonder whether ask you often you might
have any thoughts on how industry
academic in your respective areas could
contribute to such process of
policymaking the project that we were
you doing it is about moving my
expertise in intelligence expertise into
the main Stein's to organize project in
the form of challenge in the form of in
a setting that this project so it might
be similar to what all do it tackle but
with more focused on calculation courses
so it is
[Music]
kind of a platform that we in which we
produce already existing component like
my binder and docker containers that
allows to run a code of admitted
committed solutions so in the end you
get reproducible reproducible result
that can be run and understood and build
upon by anyone involved probably it is
more suitable or academic environment in
industrial environment but I think if we
[Music]
find the way how common topics relevant
many companies say things companies and
also collaborate with academia and work
on the same project even producing
meaningful result so this one one thing
and another thing quite quite important
and powerful nowadays is online
education I think it was banking we find
the way to combine online education and
for example take special courses or
specialization on ASAP and do some kind
of epitone project or a project that is
related to the topics partners might be
deficient or both parties yeah and I
think the case of optimism here is
really clear that we already have a
study suggest Igoe and were coming from
and others I don't know whether Jason or
Teddy would want to add to you
on the show you was a guest they we have
done a lot of research on the policy and
ask you about the animals ask lucky in
the likely in the Germany have put some
as as commerce planners who they're lost
like if the way if current in the
happens we can it's not the program that
if we used the sacrificed I doubt it but
when circumstances when which use the
sacrifice a human being
animal its ambi program and I think we
you know we follow this and of our
Savannah share with there was a
lawmakers of China and nothing examples
which we have a scientist thing as
seventeen we launched the project with
other tech prospers good it's the basic
idea is to his a tag has been deeply
integrated into our daily life and so
maybe it's time for us honor what
doesn't mean and our way you know
minimized possible hostile at the
Spanish years especially this task such
integration as far as not a Google has
the you know similar yeah yeah hospital
good so I would guess the you know use
that as a slogan
way our founders one of our co-founders
you know that have a rewarded you
encourage our engineers and and product
managers you know you like not know like
negative we use the head hacking right
away a one example is we have we have a
video application video so we use a
technology if you put your own too close
we are eyes either way past immediately
and give you a reminder which you know
into the way you look at is
so we I think a week and in such way we
can you know put the bar standard in
yeah unfortunately we don't have time
for questions from the audience
given that we've got a large panel but
I'm sure everyone here with the happy to
talk to you anyone who has a lot
questions thank you
[Applause]
[Music]